al sur de nueva delhi esta tienda vende
productos a base de plantas inspirados
en la medicina tradicional india nacida
hace 5.000 años el ayurveda este es el
producto estrella del momento un
medicamento que pretende sanar el
convencional esta es una excelente
protección contra el virus si alguien
tiene síntomas y toma este medicamento
mejorará de inmediato
el kit vendido por seis euros contiene
pastillas y un spray nasal este vendedor
20 25 cajas diarias sabe con la llegada
de la tercera ola a la gente teme
contagiarse con el coronavirus entonces
almacenan en casa
un tratamiento vendido sin ningún
estudio científico
detrás de este producto la marca pad
ángel y propiedades de baba ramdev un
célebre gurú hindú ferviente promotor
del yoga
su empresa es un imperio que representa
mil millones de euros de ingresos al año
para lanzar su supuesto remedio contra
el coronavirus el influyente maestro
espiritual contó incluso con la
presencia de un invitado importante
heart super dan el ministro de salud
también miembro del comité ejecutivo de
la oms y el mensaje es claro el gobierno
nacionalista hindú apoya más que nunca
el ayurveda considerado como una
alternativa a la medicina moderna
por vender y que se nos esforzamos para
que el ayurveda vuelva a ser considerado
de manera seria y científica en el mundo
entero y cuando logremos este
reconocimiento será un momento de
orgullo y gloria para ella
y baba ramdev y sería el mejor
representante y aún más controversial a
finales de mayo y medio de la segunda
ola letal
el gurú critica a la medicina
convencional a la medicina convencional
es una ciencia en decadencia
cientos de miles de indios han muerto
acudiendo a su tratamiento y distribuye
estas palabras provocaron indignación
nuestras solicitudes de entrevista a
baba ramdev y al ministro de salud
quedaron sin respuesta la asociación de
médicos indios está preocupada de ver al
gobierno apoyar a este gurú de la lluvia
el gobierno debería intervenir y decirle
que se calle este tiempo está haciendo
negocios gana cientos de millones de
euros de los pobres y pacientes
incrédulos y se aprovecha de ellos les
dice que lo sanara mejor
que los médicos son unos imbéciles
pero desde su llegada al poder el primer
ministro narendra modi se volvió el
principal lobbista de la medicina
alternativa y ello ocurre mediante la
promoción de productos a base de vaca el
animal sagrado en el hinduismo es cada
vez más explotado por sus supuestas
virtudes terapéuticas una comisión
nacional dotada con un fondo de 140
millones de euros fue creada para
impulsar la investigación y el
desarrollo de medicamentos destinados a
los humanos anexionar es uno de los
beneficiarios encabeza este centro de
jubilación para bovinos ubicado a 100
kilómetros de nueva delhi nuestras vacas
pasean por aquí para aneel la leche la
orina y la boñiga de vaca serían los
remedios para numerosas enfermedades
graves
[Música]
aquí decíamos la orina de la baja una
vez recolectada
si una persona la bebe regularmente a lo
largo de su vida no tendrá ningún
problema de inmunidad es muy benéfica
contra la diabetes el cáncer el asma la
tuberculosis y la artritis
[Música]
jabón pastillas crema dental en polvo o
jarabes son fabricados aquí y vendidos
en internet una vez más sin ningún
estudio clínico que pruebe su eficacia
bajo el gobierno anterior no nos
escuchaban no prestaban atención a
nuestras solicitudes sobre los productos
a base de vaca la naturopatía y todo lo
que constituye la sabiduría de nuestra
civilización india pero es distinto
ahora y la gente se informa cada vez más
en youtube facebook google estamos
conectados con ellos en una fracción de
segundo con la pandemia la promoción de
las pseudociencias y los remedios
milagrosos explotó en las redes sociales
y en la prensa india informaciones
falsas desmontadas día tras día por el
equipo alto news especializado en el fax
equipo suma ella chain es neurobióloga
según ella la actitud del gobierno es
netamente ideología este amor son men y
la ciencia está siendo desviada para
aprobar viejos y mitos que sabemos que
son falsos
por ejemplo afirman que la cirugía fue
inventada hace cinco mil años pero la
anestesia no existía aún en aquella
época la ciencia es usada igualmente
para impulsar el nacionalismo y con
fines puramente positivos
ciencia política y religión un cóctel
peligroso cada vez más difícil de tragar
para los científicos indios